ah x-files fans you hear that music
we're only three days away from the
return of Mulder and Scully and I can
tell you to get ready for a few big
surprises we have an exclusive interview
with the show's creator and he's
dropping some spoilers and we are
breaking this new x-files down by the
numbers
skully
how important were the fans in getting
this to happen well if we didn't think
they were gonna watch it we wouldn't
have pushed so hard to do it I think
important yeah their loyalty over the
years is pretty incredible what if
everything we've been led to believe in
is a lot no Alan it's been 22 years
since we first met agents Mulder and
Scully after nine seasons that's 200 two
episodes plus two movies it's time to
believe again with six new episodes from
creator Chris Carter originally we're
asked through eight episodes but we had
to scale back our series order because
the actors just didn't have time to do
any more couldn't you be jumping to
conclusions another number you're going
to love - as in the number of spoilers
we can tell you spoiler number one
Mulder and Scully's romance is over I
can tell you all is not well as we come
back they are no longer living together
they are living separate lives
spoiler number two Chris has already
written a secret third x-files movie I
never even showed it to David and
Jillian it was really just for me to
sort of keep the characters alive in my
head I think it would need to be a
really big screen event all this
translates to big bucks
a billion dollar x-files industry reruns
alone have sold for two hundred and
thirty million dollars and a commercial
on Sundays premiere will set you back
around six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars the question is will these six
new episodes be enough to satisfy fans
we really have to see how we're gonna do
in the ratings and if the fans are happy
I'm sure we'll be asked for more I think
this thing has a chance because Fox is
giving it a great timeslot the show
premieres Sunday night right after the
NFC Championship Game everybody will
tune in and of course that is one of the
top-rated programs of the year they're
making sure it scores a touchdown look
at you Saturday